in reality when you looked at the stuff
that Andrew Tate spoke about one of the
things he spoke about quite a bit was
polygamy and it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to figure out that
Christianity is against polygamy
regardless of what some of the folks in
the comment section might like to say
it's very clear that God from the
beginning created them male and female
in a monogamous relationship and I think
part of the reason that he might be
moving from Romania to the United Arab
Emirates is because the UAE allows for
polygamous matters are you seeing what's
going on here so I'm not very surprised
first and foremost listen Andrew Tate
had the ability at least again with a
lot of different women why on Earth
would he want to get married
to a limit limitation of four
that doesn't make sense if you look at
Abraham he had two wives if you look at
uh Solomon in the Bible he had a few
hundred wives it's like why are you
acting like there's no such thing as as
a multitude of wives in in the Bible at
all
Andrew Tate is a person
who says that even Christians and we
discussed this earlier first and
foremost that Christianity is not
something that really enforces their
values and Views and that he was only a
Christian because that was the the
dominant religion of Romania he didn't
he didn't say I'm a Christian because I
truly believe in this enough and so on
and so forth he was a Christian because
that was the dominant power in religious
power in Romania so to say that he only
moved there the only reason is because
of polygeny Habibi the Habibi he could
have a 20 000 women night after night
after night
if he wanted to in Romania and not have
to marry any of them he was trying to
like say everything like dead on that's
it like you knew everything that he was
talking about he's not one he's not one
you know like we we should we should
look at what
Jesus said right the actual gospel but
the thing is is that the actual gospel
can't be found the actual gospel it's
been it's been lost
what we have today is just like this
butchering of things that we don't even
know what's real what's not real what
what Jesus peace be upon him said and
what he didn't say it's like the book
that you showed me bro the book where
you have the actual New Testament
Scholars
they looked at it and they said okay
this is what he said this is what he
might have said this is what he
definitely didn't say
show them bro let them have it
this is the book there it is let me flip
my camera just for this let me put my
camera just for this
boom I'll look uglier but you can read
the book The Five Guys didn't change
anything bro
and I'll bless you the five gospels by
the Jesus seminar it has a multitude of
New Testament Scholars
you see there's there's a big a bit of
gray a bit of black a bit of pink so
they put in uh Red Letters things Jesus
most likely said they put in pink
letters like here things he probably
said they put in Gray letters like here
things he probably didn't say and they
put in bold black things Jesus
definitely did not say and when you flip
through the book
oh get the get the book closer to the
middle but they can't see the book uh uh
okay so when you flip through the book
what's the the majority it's mostly
black bro mostly black which means most
of the things in the New Testament and
to be fair it's the five gospels
including the Gospel of Thomas which
Christians don't see as canonical
um mainly because it doesn't talk about
the crucifixion or resurrection of Jesus
but
um you can see most of the things that
are narrated are have nothing to do with
Jesus and they're not what Jesus said
according to New Testament Scholars and
if you look at uh someone like I know
Christians maybe don't like bar Ehrman
but he is a new testament scholar he's
done debates with other New Testament
Scholars you can go watch those he
mentions that there's a unanimous
agreement there's the unanimous opinion
that the The Originals will not be found
in New Testament Scholars stopped using
the term Originals original gospels
because they know it will not be found
right we should we should be following
what Jesus peace be upon him was
actually preaching but the thing is is
that again what he originally preached
has been altered it can no longer be
found we don't know exactly what he was
saying during that time but what we
didn't know
is exactly what the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said and it's he's
literally saying it that this is what
Allah is saying that every single
Prophet has been preaching these same
exact thing and every time there's an
alteration that's when God comes back
and resend the message brings it back
and that's why if you look at it it's
like okay if listen if Christianity if
Christianity was
the final
religion if Christianity was exactly
what it was supposed to be if it truly
is Christianity it was truly supposed to
accept Jesus as our savior
and repent to him and all this stuff
why is it
that there has been a final
Testament
right the final testament which is the
Quran the final religion which is Islam
and it preaches the exact same message
that all the abrahamic faiths
have been preaching from the beginning
except without alteration
I mean come on come on bro 100 and I
think as an additive I want to add a
question
Islam very clearly deals with
Christianity it does in the Quran very
clearly deals with Christianity Judaism
polytheism basically every mainstream
understanding of life that exists I'd
say every understanding of life it deals
with that in some way Christianity has
no explanation for Islam other than well
it's just the devil the work of the
devil trying to misguide people okay
they have nothing concrete nothing solid
as an argument against Islam or against
the prophet Muhammad peace upon him even
when you look at the Bible like in
Deuteronomy I think it's 23 I'm not sure
but when you look at Deuteronomy it says
that essentially gives a criteria that
you can tell if a prophet is a true
Prophet by his prophecies so you're
going to tell me that's in the Bible and
then God's going to allow a man to come
to make like hundreds of prophecies and
basically all of them come true
and then we still have to reject him as
a prophet even though in the Bible it
says if his prophecies are true then
he's a true Prophet he's spoken the
truth come on there's there's many many
shortcomings but I would love to talk to
one of these or both of these guys
um on the podcast or if they don't want
to talk in public we can do in private
as well because they do seem very
genuine inshallah and I think the last
thing that I want to say
in regards to
um Christianity as a whole in my
experience this is my experience okay
it's not the 100 the truth
um that that I would say right but from
what I noticed is that most Christians
right they'll say that they're Christian
and they'll stick to that they'll stand
by that yeah
because they're just attached they're
attached to it and it is the ego the ego
attachment and they can't let go of the
ego they can't submit the ego fully and
actually submit themselves yeah like 100
percent
again and I see that from my experience
at all yeah because every every
Christian that I've come across even
myself when I was Christian like
they don't submit I didn't submit bro I
can't say I ever fully submitted to God
it's like yeah I had we all had those
moments where like we you know things at
times are getting really rough we feel
really low and we get into those moments
we're like oh
um we feel more humble and we're getting
closer to God but it's it's not until
you fully submit yourself
that you really
get close to God really experience God
and that really only happens
when you practice
as a Muslim
why because it's it's the exact proper
guidelines right as a Christian there
aren't really the guidelines
you know like okay they might argue
might say oh no there are there's in the
book this is listen bro like
as Christians they really only pray
like when
like Sunday service maybe oh I'm about
to eat let me say prayer before I eat
um maybe before going to sleep or
something like that or maybe they might
only pray like when times are hard and
they want to ask for like things to be
easier or help or or something like this
right
you can't you can't fully connect with a
gun
if that's how you're playing like again
like this is
this is not
I don't know I feel like if I keep going
it's just redundant so I'm just gonna
keep it there again my experience with
the Christians that I've come into
contact with with myself as I was a
Christian
and uh just something to take into
consideration
and with that being said
foreign